all right uh welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone it is an honor to host the
anima
um anandukuma who is a brand professor
at Caltech and director of ml research
at Nvidia she was previously a principal
scientist at Amazon web services
um anima is really a pine pine Pioneer
Pioneer of the neural operators and
today she is going to talk about ml for
solving pdes neural operators on the
function spaces
um yeah so Animas yeah thank you all
yours thank you and great to be here
sorry for the delay I you know the WebEx
I haven't used in a long time so and now
I had some teething problems but yeah so
I'm happy to talk about neural operators
and what is the methodology behind it
why that is suitable for different
scientific applications including
solving partial differential equations
and also why not just the standard
neural network tools right what is
special about neural operators
yeah so indeed you know if you want to
think about modeling multi-scale
processes uh in a variety of scientific
domains uh you know this is very
challenging right I mean the scales are
enormous you can go all the way down to
problems at the quantum level looking at
uh interactions as wave functions uh
between electrons in a molecule and
using that to predict the properties uh
especially when it comes to designing
new drugs or materials this is important
all the way to the planetary scale if
you want to predict the weather or
climate how we can look at
microscopic interactions and the impact
it has globally at planetary scales and
that's the aspect that is so challenging
to model and of course there's so many
other problems in between as well that
are multi-scale in nature and this is
different from Tech story match
processing right that you've seen a lot
of exciting developments but that
doesn't directly translate into our
ability to model these processes um text
is discrete data
again image processing
typically you just think of doing that
at one fixed resolution right and it's
object-centric in natural images you our
main goal is to reduce from this pixel
space to some low dimensional
representation that is centered around
objects you know for instance segmenting
the objects being able to recognize the
objects so that's where a lot of the
focus is on right going from these pixel
dimensions to lower dimensional space on
the other hand if you think about these
multi-scale processes there's
information in all scales right so you
cannot ex very easily reduce it to some
high level representation like we do
with image processing and so we need to
think of different Frameworks to be able
to
nicely capture all of the scales and do
High Fidelity modeling and as an example
I want to show the challenges in
modeling climate the one big source of
uncertainty in fact the biggest source
of uncertainty is the presence of these
low-lying clouds what we call
stratocumulus clouds and the turbulence
in them so the ability to model the
turbulence at very fine spatial and
temporal scales is important in order to
get
uh very you know the right answers or
the uh in these micro scales ultimately
impact the macro behavior and what my
colleague tapio Schneider estimates is
you really need to go down to one meter
special resolution planet-wide and that
requires about 100 billion times more
Computing than what we have today
and so if we are trying to do standard
numerical methods and we need to go to
these fine scales it's just very Out Of
Reach to be able to do that right in a
Brute Force Manner and so right now of
our capabilities are barely getting to
one kilometer right so that's also not
fully there we are you know still
getting to that resolution and so
there's a big gap between what we can do
today versus what we really need to do
to capture the fine scales in climate
modeling and so that's just one of the
examples the same is true with quantum
chemistry or multitude of other examples
I showed you we
cannot get to the level of computation
needed to capture all the scales of the
problem and also you know in this case
we are going from bottom-up physics
right so we are starting with partial
differential equations each time we are
redoing all of the computations to get
us to the answers so the question is
what is the role of data-driven methods
that could learn from previous data and
be able to do these computations much
faster
so this is where I think machine
learning can have a very big impact uh
you know helping us build on top of
accelerated Computing you know gpus or
indeed the Workhorse of AI so getting
all those hardware accelerations and
efficiency and of course super Computing
scale so we'll use all of that but
machine learning is really the enabler
of that scale right it's going to help
us LeapFrog and get us very big speed
UPS in terms of being able to do much
faster computations you know if we can
avoid the fine grid required for
numerical methods and get away with
coarser grids the getaway uh with not
having to do intermediate iterations and
get to the answers faster because we
learned the features that are relevant
to that domain then we can really
LeapFrog in our computational abilities
and I think that's the promise and we'll
also see in many applications we are
able to get very impressive speed ups
and we're able to maintain the Fidelity
or sometimes even surpass it compared to
traditional methods
yeah so let me first start with the
framework and give an overview of what
neural operator is right so what makes
it different from standard neural
networks I think I told you uh just a
few slides ago that we cannot use the
same models as text or image processing
because we need to capture all of the
scales and I think that's the key
difference if we used any of the
standard neural networks for image
processing whether it's convolutional
neural network or Vision Transformers
that typically trained to
work at a fixed resolution so you have
training data at one resolution and you
also have testing data at the same
resolution
on the other hand if we are thinking
about
solving scientific problems as I
mentioned we need to capture many
different scales and not only that we
need to be able to query at any scale
right so if you use any of the
scientific methods any numerical methods
we have the flexibility of having
different grids right so in fact
different problems entail different
shapes of grids for instance the airfoil
you know typically we have this
non-uniform grid because you want more
finer grid near these sharp points and
so this flexibility to go different
shapes of grids as well as query at any
point because the phenomenon is a
continuous domain is important and so
standard neural networks don't have that
capability and so the question is how do
we design neural operators that can
mimic the capabilities of current
numerical methods but are also
having high fidelity are expressive
they're able to capture the multi-scale
phenomena and they're fast right so we
need to be able to do all of this at
once
so that's where our inspiration comes
from the ability to solve first linear
partial differential equations so as a
thought process if we start with asking
what is an efficient way to learn
solutions for linear partial
differential equations uh you know you
can think of
this form of the solution right the
inverse of differential operator is the
integral operator and we can look
towards building
a block here that learns to solve this
integral linear operator so this is now
a building block that can solve linear
partial differential equations for
instance the heat diffusion equation is
a linear partial differential equation
and in some cases we even know this
kernel or the screens functional
analytically in other cases you have to
numerically compute it but the key is
here solving linear partial differential
equations involves
you know learning the kernel or the
screen's function and also being able to
integrate that on the continuous domain
so because this integration is over the
continuous domain you can now give your
input at any different discretization
right and you would still be able to
hang out the output be at any
discretization so that's the key
difference from a standard neural
network where the input is only in a
fixed discretization a fixed grid here
we have the flexibility to have the
input in any point in the continuous
domain because it's Computing this
integration at any point
and so that's the key aspect that is uh
you know will be different from standard
neural networks and also now the
question is how do we compute this
efficiently right so there is two
aspects one is how do we compute this
efficiently the other aspect is how do I
extend this Beyond linear equations to
non-linear equations you know so many
phenomena of interest that I showed you
fluid dynamics for climate modeling or
quantum chemistry right so you know many
of the especially the approximations of
that become non-linear uh problems so we
need to be able to
handle non-linearity
and so that's where we introduce a more
General framework that takes these
blocks that learn integral linear
operators and compose that with
non-linearity
so these compositions of integral linear
operators with non-linear activations
you know they can be standard non-linear
activations like relu or gallu are
usually yellow because we want also
second order derivatives right in many
of these differential equations they
involve second order derivatives so we
want that smoothness and so we use a
function like Galu for um a non-linear
activation but that's a detail but the
general framework is that by composing
linear blocks with non-linear
activations we get an expressive model
and this is the same philosophy as a
standard neural network because even
there you have a linear function and you
compose with non-linear activation the
linear function in uh fully connected
neural network is matrix multiplication
in convolutional neural network is
convolution right by the same philosophy
holds here that
we compute a linear operator and then we
compose with non-linearity the only
difference is this is now learning a
linear operator as opposed to a linear
function so this operator Maps a
continuous input token an input in a
continuous domain to uh but output which
is also a function on continuous domain
right so that's the main difference
anima uh Madi has a question
um about are the inputs here location
time and the outputs the solution of the
equations
so the input can be both space and time
right so to me input is any function on
a continuous domain
and that domain could be space or time
or both or anything else as well
so this General framework is you know
that's that's one option
okay thank you
great and again yeah if there are
further questions here do uh feel free
to interrupt me
so that's the framework
um now of course one thing I haven't
told you is how to learn these integral
linear operators efficiently
and so one framework that has been very
successful is what we call Fourier
neural operator where uh we uh relax the
kernel to a convolutional kernel so
meaning you are you know only look at
translations right and this is uh indeed
um a limitation compared to the general
kernel but because we compose it with
non-linear activations we can show that
it's still expressive and in fact you
know both this original
neural operator as well as the
convolution based neural operator are
both Universal approximators so you can
approximate any non-linear operator uh
which is a mapping from one function
space to another with these Frameworks
and I think this is important to be able
to capture as I said any non-linear
operator
so but of course this I have just made
this simplification but what is this
bias right why is this more efficient to
learn a convolutional operator so this
is where we can do change of basis we
can go from convolution to element-wise
multiplication in the four-year domain
for instance so we know Fourier basis is
a good inductive bias for many problems
including fluid dynamics it's been used
for numerical methods as well so we can
use that inspiration and say Fourier
domain is a good inductory bias and not
only that it becomes
much more efficient to learn the
coefficients in the Fourier domain right
so this way the integration over the
continuous domain just becomes matrix
multiplication so this is efficient and
we can learn
the coefficients in an efficient manner
so that's the principle it's very simple
that we can transform our input into the
Fourier domain we learn the coefficients
in the Fourier domain and we go back to
the standard domain and then we do
non-linearity in the standard domain
which could be space and time and we
could then repeat this again
so a few points here right so first of
all
um you know if it did just this
convolutional operator in the Fourier
domain without non-linearity that would
be limiting
right so and in fact that's what the
numerical methods to they transform to
the
Fourier domain and digits to iteration
there
um on the other hand we have non-linear
Activation so we have the now
flexibility to not just you know it's
not just limited to the Fourier spectrum
of the original signal we're also
learning features over non-linear
activations so that's a benefit the
other benefit we can get is through
regularization or we can capture only
the low frequency modes in the first
layer so we just filter out and only
retain low frequency modes here of
course if you didn't have non-linearity
this would be a strong aliasing right so
this would lead to errors because many
signals of Interest have high frequency
components so you can't just threshold
them but on the other hand because we
have non-linear activations present we
can further transform the signal and
still have the ability to capture high
frequency content and that's why we are
able to provide the guarantees of
universal approximation even though in
each layer we are using a regularization
to keep low frequency modes of course
that's a hyper parameter of how much do
you threshold to retain low frequency
modes versus how many layers do you have
right so both are hyper parameters we
can choose for different problems
but really the benefit is the ability to
now make learning efficient as well as
keep the discretization invariance
meaning I can now input my signal at any
resolution or you know with any
resolution I can still
capture the signal through Fourier
transform right because I can do Fourier
transform at any resolution and that's a
key ingredient that makes this overall
framework end-to-end discretization
invariant by that what I mean is let me
first show you just an example a proof
of concept in terms of showing how we
can you know train in one resolution and
test in a different resolution right
which wouldn't be possible with standard
neural networks so we're training using
only course resolution data for this
navier Stokes equation
and we do that over different initial
conditions and then at testing time we
provide higher resolution inputs and
then we look at how well does it predict
right and what we see is indeed that
does predict pretty well and in can see
that in fact in the frequency spectrum
as well that the prediction is very
graceful even beyond the
I've seen resolution meaning it
extrapolates to higher resolution
without seeing it during training so
this is what we mean by zero shot super
resolution and you can see that here
um that you know there is right I mean
these systems are dissipative so you do
have see the drop off of the energy
Spectrum but you know when we're giving
training data at a fixed resolution we
only see these wave numbers right so
these we have no idea what the higher
wave numbers are but in cases where
there is uh a nice drop of our framework
is able to track that compared to uh
other standard Frameworks like qnet I
think there was another question
yes there was another question by Maddie
um he said this also assumes that the
set of equations that represents the
physics in one scale is also valid in on
other scale right yeah we are currently
assuming there's only a fixed set of
equations right so the way I mean I
haven't even used the equations right so
if you're using the equations in a
physics informed manner that would
matter in this case we are just giving
data right there's no physics knowledge
built into the model but what really you
know where this will work well is when
there's a nice drop off in terms of
energy right in these higher frequencies
if you for instance have something very
arbitrary like this right some arbitrary
Spectrum here that is having very high
energy content you know we cannot expect
to capture it because we have absolutely
no information about that all right he
also asked what is what is the
difference between two scales Vector of
10 factor of hundred you can see that
here right the wave numbers so these are
the wave numbers we provide we can go
all the way up to 100 so we provide a
little more than what it's 25 wave
numbers or 30 something like that and
and we can go much further we can go to
any scale right the prediction can
happen at any scale sounds good thank
you anima yeah
yeah so just to kind of make this point
about discretization in variance what
can we can be guarantee right as I
mentioned we cannot guarantee that we
will give you as error free answer at
any resolution because that's impossible
if we do not see higher resolution
inputs you know there's no way we can
capture all of the information about it
on the other hand what we can guarantee
is graceful
you know degradation right Grace like
kind of having consistent answers even
as we refine the mesh so the idea is you
keep refining the mesh and asking what
is the value at any point here you
should converge to a limit and ideally
that limit should be closer to the
ground truth operator right so so what
we're guaranteeing is this kind of
convergence and this is something you
may not you know otherwise see in other
Frameworks and so just to kind of make
that point clear you know standard
neural networks do not have this ability
because most of them you can't even
query at any resolution right so the
standard architectures expect always the
resolution to be fixed whereas neural
operators remove that dependence there's
of course an intermediate step where you
could use interpolation on top of
standard neural network so you train
your neural network at a fixed
resolution you use a standard fixed
interpolation whether it's bilinear
interpolation or any such framework you
can use on top where there's no learning
for interpolation so that framework
indeed allows you to query anywhere in
the domain but it does not guarantee
Universal approximation because the
neural network just learns at a fixed
scale right so it is not learning in the
function space like we do with neural
operators and that to me is the big
benefit we obtain here
yeah so just to reiterate the framework
of neural operators is
taking uh you know ways to compute these
integral linear operator and composing
with non-linearity to give it both
expressivity but by Learning Blocks that
compute integral linear operators we
still keep discretization invariance and
so that kind of like you know ability to
have both aspects of discretization
invariance and non-linearity is crucial
so there's an extensive Library I
encourage you to go check it out you
know it's open source also contribute to
it would be great to hear your thoughts
where we do have implementations of the
Fourier neural operator that I mentioned
but also there are other approaches
right in order to be able to estimate
this for instance through graph based
method because you can learn through
a graph neural network uh and message
passing what is the relationship between
nearby points and then you can turn it
into an operator because once you learn
the kernel you can approximate the
integration as summation
so this works well if the phenomena is
fairly local so it's much harder to do
for Global dependence like in fluid
dynamics because you would need the
neighborhood to be very large and that
is expensive so I think there are
Frameworks where the graph based methods
are effective and then the other domains
especially with uh where we know the
operator is highly non-local where
Fourier based methods are effective
because you know we can express these
kind of global dependence efficiently
through Fourier transforms
yeah so far what I mentioned was just
Computing on a
you know a practical implementation was
Computing on a uniform grid right
because Fourier transform the efficient
implementation is fast Fourier transform
that assumes uniform grid and if you try
to do Fourier transform or non-uniform
grids show that our algorithms but those
implementations are not efficient and so
we wanted to keep the Fourier transform
as fast Fourier transform on uniform
grid and the way we you know decided to
handle non-uniform input domains right
the physical space for instance this
airfoil Wing this is a irregular
geometry shape and we also want a grid
to be irregular to capture that
non-uniformity
so this is our input domain so what we
propose is to learn a deformation from
this to
um
a uniform Grid in a latent space and we
know from topology that such
deformations exist so if you assume this
is homeomorphic toy Taurus you can learn
the transformation right and and if not
you can also there you decompose the
domain into multiple parts and piece
them together which is a detail from
topology but the idea is this is very
general so in general you should be able
to learn the Transformations from a
physical space that is irregular to a
latent space that is regular
and so what we do is we learn such
deformations Point wise and this way we
can go to a latent space and do
efficient computations and come back to
the standard domain and so you can see
that where we predict deformation for
plastic forging here and again we see
you know really impressive speed UPS
about 100 000 times speed up over
standard numerical methods and you can
see that geometry is changing over time
and it's able to maintain and do that
prediction
so this is another example where we you
know
can handle a regular shape ah in the
sense that the fluid is now flowing
through a catheter with all these
triangular shapes right so we propose
triangular shapes as a way to limit the
bacterial contamination so what's known
as the bacteria swim upstream to the
fluid flow and if it can reduce the
a bacteria by trapping it in these
triangular places then we can reduce the
contamination and so one benefit with
these methods is that we can do inverse
design very effectively so not just
inverse design any kind of inverse
problems because the trained neural
operators are differentiable right so we
can directly get the gradients back and
so what we did was to ask you know how
can I find the optimal triangular shape
to minimize the bacterial contamination
so here the contamination should be
ideally zero because we don't want the
bacteria going back into the patient and
so we were able to do that by doing
gradient descent which is very fast and
effective and that's how we
um you know were able to very quickly
propose a design on our collaborators 3D
printed it and tested it in the lab and
this is just a visualization of you know
how you can see many particles are
getting trapped in these triangular
grooves
yeah and so this is another here uh
demonstration with airfoil if you want
to optimize for lift versus drag right
we can directly do gradient descent and
come up with this and here we are
having the simulation of the fluid
dynamics around the aircraft Wing right
so we are only training for the forward
model so in the forward model we have
many different aircraft Wings we are
predicting how you know what is the
fluid dynamics around that and and then
we can directly do the inverse problems
so the key is you don't need to know
what is the optimal design when you're
doing the training of the neural
operator
and you can do the inverse and come up
with the optimal design
yeah so far I did not incorporate any of
the physics I think there was a question
earlier asteroid so you know how does It
capture the different scales so
in you know in terms of uh if you want
to really capture the fine scales and we
need to do that with high accuracy we
would need to know the equations as well
and so the idea is if the data is only
at course resolution I now have the
flexibility to express my equations at a
much finer resolution and so this way we
can capture both data and the equations
and we can get to High Fidelity results
and so we can then do zero short super
resolution uh very well even at higher
resolutions
and we can also further fine-tune our
model because you know during training
we have a variety of initial conditions
and solutions but at this time we have a
single initial condition right so we
want to do well on this we can further
fine tune with the equation laws on this
specific instance and that way we get to
our better error
and so we can also do better transfer
learning with physics-based losses
because we can you know learn the
operator safe on one Reynolds number if
you want to fine tune on a different
Reynolds number there is a
distributional shift but having the
equation loss allows us to quickly
figure out what the distribution changed
right what parameter change and still
utilize the information that was you
know in the earlier train model and so
this leads to faster convergence
um yeah so so far what I told you was to
learn deterministic Maps between
function spaces right what about
learning probability distributions on
function spaces and indeed this directly
you know asks similar questions as we've
seen with generative AI whether it's
text Generation image generation right
so they're all learning probability
distributions can we do the same and
indeed for scientific Computing that's
very important right so inverse problems
if you want the posterior of your
inverse problem that's a probability
distribution naturally right uncertainty
quantification
um learning like chaotic Dynamics so you
want to ask what are the different
attractors and what is their
distribution so all of this are problems
that require probability distribution
and of course if you're looking at
stochastic differential equations or
rather
processes those are also you know
involve learning probability on function
spaces so what we've recently
um
derived is a diffusion model but now on
function spaces
and so we are doing that by extending
what is known as core function in
diffusion models in finite dimensional
spaces to now score operator right so
this operator Maps a function space of
of one domain to another and in this
case what we want to do is map instead
of gaussian noise a gaussian random
field to the output distribution and so
this is the key difference here with
gaussian random field you can now sample
at any resolution so you're no longer
limited to sampling at the resolution of
the training data like we see in image
generation models and that's how we can
now you know do this training at low
resolution and generate high resolution
images and still get you know very good
Fidelity of what we generate right so if
you now have a density of initial
conditions you want to capture that
random distribution
of solutions for these given initial
conditions in this example you can see
that we can do very well
so I wanted to see if there are further
questions before I maybe showcase one or
two examples of using these various
methods yeah Matty do you want to meet
yourself
um I see you please raise your hand
Madi are you there
I don't I don't hear it okay see any
other questions from audience
animal you can move on
I think there's another question uh
um no yeah I'm yeah I yeah I don't think
so you can move on okay
yeah so to give you some examples you
know we trained um using these Fourier
neural operator and its variants on
weather data so but this is
um era 5 reanalysis data that's
available since the 1970s so having this
wealth of historical weather data allows
us to train a model that's very accurate
as well as fast so here's a
visualization of the atmospheric rivers
and you can see that it can capture
these very wide you know that are those
are thousands of miles wide phenomena
that has a huge impact on whether there
are storms or drought in the western
coast here
and not only that it's very fast it's
about 45 000 times faster than current
numerical weather models
so you can also see that with trajectory
prediction we can you know predict these
wind conditions and the high wind
conditions are in purple and you can see
our prediction closely follows the
trajectory of Hurricane Matthew which
was certainly not in the training data
right so we are looking at how well it
does on new hurricanes and it's able to
give you a good uncertainty bound around
the trajectory of the hurricane so these
are some more details and we also have
some of our models open source there I
welcome you to go check it out and what
you can see is the ability to have big
speed UPS over current numerical weather
models and at the same time good
accuracy so what would take hours on a
CPU cluster for current numerical by the
models takes less than a second on a
single desktop GPU
yeah and we continue to improve this I
think we just recently talked I think
yesterday the talk was at iClear
workshop on climate AI where by
incorporating the spherical geometry so
instead of the Fourier fast Fourier
transform on euclidean Space we now have
spherical harmonics and we build that
into our model and that leads to even
better extrapolation so you can do much
longer rollouts than what we
had trained for we trained it just for a
few time steps of six hours or so right
so we have a very short range training
but we can extrapolate the model to long
rollouts and there's good stability and
we continue to improve the forecasting
skills as well compared to the ifs which
is the you know current numerical
weather models
so we've also used in a number of other
scenarios to mitigate climate change
carbon capture and storage is a big
aspect so how do we model the buildup of
pressure as carbon dioxide is pumped
into these Wells so we are now able to
do multi-well modeling so being able to
look at multiple Wells at once and if
you have a permeability map so you know
how permeable the ground is and we can
then use that as the input given a
permeability map we have high resolution
a fine grid prediction within the wells
as well as a coarser grid to connect the
different Wells and you can see that we
can model the gas plume Evolution as
well as the pressure buildup and we can
do that over 30 year range and we can
even do further if needed but the key is
you can see that it has a very big speed
up about 7 100 000 times faster than
current numerical weather models
so these are applicable in many other
scenarios as well you know predicting
air turbulence for drone flights or
other flights is important
so we've been uh testing it in the lab
by looking at turbulent conditions here
and using laser measurements and showing
that we can do very nice real-time fluid
prediction directly from noisy
experimental data and so we continue to
test models like this also in the right
physical Hardware on the lab to see how
well we can stabilize uh the airfoil
wing and many other cases
so just to show like at Caltech we also
have the fan array where we can test
this very carefully on different kinds
of wind conditions
so I think I already mentioned the
cathedral before so let me yeah so
um you know again sorry for the delay
but I hope you got a good overview of
what neural operators are what is the
principle behind designing them and how
they differ from standard neural
networks and their ability to capture
multiple scales and do
inferences in a discretization invariant
manner
thank you sounds good thank you so much
for the wonderful talk animal
um I guess did I miss the the question
from the Joseph let's have a q a
sessions by the way
um Joseph asked are there any special
considerations for using neural operator
operators on inverse problems
um so there are different options right
so you can do the you can learn the
neural operator uh for the forward
problem and then just take Radiance
differentiate through the model or you
can directly learn the inverse mapping
and so there are both options or you can
couple both of them as well
um and also in both of these cases you
can ask you know how do I
also incorporate the physics right so
you can also do the physics informed
version and then there is the aspect
that to capture the not just point
estimates but to get the right posterior
distribution you know can we use
diffusion models so what I propose
diffusion models on function spaces
thank you okay another question by
Huawei for the CCS case have your team
try to explore the super resolution
property of Albano
yeah we can certainly
predictions but we
are now working with some Partners
getting real data and validating on that
awesome okay next question is by fatal
what do you need to train the neural
operator do you need the original pde
can you learn on noisy ground truth yeah
so we don't need the original pde right
so the framework I described was very
general the input can be any function on
a domain and the output is a function
right so you're learning that mapping
and so you can take data from solvers
existing solvers like I showed you the
navier Stokes example or you can take
the weather example where the data is
already there the historical by the data
the re-analysis data and we train on it
so it can be very general sounds good
okay if the equations are there we can
incorporate that as a loss function in
addition
edges is still in pinot right
okay the next question is by rui Pang
and he has the photo function mapping to
learn from pde coefficient to solution
any ideas what function spaces it is in
and is the mapping unique
so for to learn from the coefficients to
the solutions you know they
the unique solution right but we don't
need to even assume that as long as we
have the data that learns the mapping we
can do that but of course if it's Unique
then you have a good error and you can
learn this well all right sounds good so
um I don't think there is any other
question but I have a question you can
reach the hands story yeah I think yeah
I so for for the for the FML can I say
more about like the boundary conditions
especially like non-pure periodical
boundary conditions and also for the
like the in the carbon storage case you
showed that to have like uh like the
course created far fields and also like
near the well like I have the high high
resolution great so how you make the the
boundary conditions consistency between
these two yeah that's a that's a great
point so for the first generally like
for non-periodic uh cases right the
Fourier Branch may not capture that very
easily I mean you can't correct that
with Fourier continuation methods and we
also proposed that but we also have
alternative Branch food so we have skip
connections and so that's a very
efficient way to cap capture a
non-periodic
conditions and so we we have
architectures that handle that very
efficiently so in terms of like for the
specific uh you know case of uh CCS what
we did was a nested fno model so we now
have different fno models for you know
within the Well versus outside we have
multiple levels and uh yeah so they just
share the information across them
that makes
sounds good do you have more questions
no okay
um so FNL is known to require many many
data so
um
and from your experience it you know if
you incorporate the physics then do you
see that you require the last data is
required absolutely our data requirement
goes down significantly and of course it
depends on the hardness of the problem
right so you know some cases you may
even do with one data point that's the
physics informed neural network setting
right so if the optimization landscape
is very efficient you don't need any
data at all you can directly solve for
the equation laws and then there are
others that are high dimensional and
very hard and you may need more data so
there's a whole spectrum of problems
okay sounds good
um I have a just clarify clarification
questions you said that people net is
not discretization Independence I I
thought he was discretized so so there's
a so the original Deep on it that was uh
proposed was on assuming a fixed input
grid
so the input grid was assumed to be
fixed the output is also is still a
function so the output is
can work at any resolution but the input
was a fixed grid and then later on in a
while right proposed a solution others
proposed to solution as well to fix that
but anyway I wanted the the original one
happened yeah I just wanted to clarify
of course but I think the current
version of The Depot net yeah that
doesn't it's independent out there okay
um another question from CEO one Chang
what is the regularity assumptions
needed in the function spaces if the
solution is of low regularity for
example the domain is singular and the
functional is rough then the current
framework be applied yeah so we are
working on like kind of extensions of
this in terms of practical architecture
but there's already Theory showing that
you can use Fourier neural operator to
approximate those well as well like Sam
Lander and Andrew Steward have like a
recent paper but yeah this is something
we're working on
okay yeah I have another question uh
foreign learning
um if the the
differential equations are different
like for different problems do you think
that transfer learning is still helpful
or not I know like in the same equations
probably it's like a helpful from uh but
but from the point of view of a
difference the differential equations
yeah that's great and and that's unclear
right it's again the same as any
you know what we see in other Vision
domains like how much is the shared
features you might think some of it is
still shared because numerical methods
right like kind of have
similar approaches for all of these
domains so it may still transfer but
yeah it's a good question you know how
effective it is we haven't tried it so
far
yeah comments on on that chinkai I mean
transfer learning not on the neural
operator but the on the traditional
neural network sensing a sense uh it has
been applied you know you know yeah
different pde and you know use that to
accelerate the another neural net model
for that another PVE that has been
demonstrated but I guess it's an example
by example yeah exactly yeah but it's I
think I think think I expect that there
should still be an advantage yes some
some unusable right
all right any other questions from
audiences
um
oh yes we do okay
um as uh the question from protano when
you compare the speed up to you consider
the training or data generation time so
you know no in these numbers we don't
first of all it's still not a
significant amount right so because to
me data is just something that uh you
know you only do training once right and
then inference is running cost and so
this is the standard way we would
evaluate any method so because also
there is cost that goes into programming
these algorithms even for traditional
methods so so I would just you know to
me that's uh something that you know
happens before the solver comes online
but we do report that in our papers
got it uh another question by Maddie can
the method extrapolate to new and unseen
geometries
yeah in the the geometric fno that I
proposed EI does that's how you can see
that even online changing geometry of
the deformation it's able to track
but you should have some mapping from
you know once geometry to another that
no we just learned that we learned that
now okay yeah
all right
different trees that's how we're able to
generalize it
all right sounds good is there any other
questions from audience
if not let's thank our speaker anema for
the wonderful talk and and good
discussion times
and thanks everyone and thanks for
sticking around I really appreciate it
thank you yeah and I do reach out if you
have further questions that would be
awesome okay thank you thank you
thank you everyone we have another tdps
seminar tomorrow so see you tomorrow
bye now thank you bye